a mills em 321 op o pessoal aqui quem
fala daqui são muito bem vindos mas o
meu e você só que digo que o estúdio em
32 o que eu acabei de receber um um
barulho forte no haiti na vida real
vejam só está muito velha jogo já está
com o espírito bancar tudo bem amarelo e
ele é verdadeiramente feito em madeira e
metal pintura támbém cartune meu deus tá
muito bom esse casamento com uma cisma
uma escola e provaram isso para o brasil
aqui em casa eu nem cheguei foi
construir - df no embalo dourado com
certeza tem boas coisas mas só expira
vão descobrir tanto faz eu até o fim e
que não viu no vídeo anterior conforme
parecer e e que houve onde o bebê as
funções ainda prevê que todas as
posições meu desejo eu acho que elas
devem ser muito mal agora nem vou tentar
provar estas questões porque estava já
está aqui há muito tempo então isso que
deve ser muito mau mas vamos fazer o
teste só lá vou perder essa opção
meu deus eu tô com medo eu toco muito
medo até tenho títulos aqui em cima já
com decisão e tudo o que eu acho que vou
morrer
bora lá pessoal vamos fazer o texto e
cheira muito mal juro
aí já está gostando muito ao peru para
lá em 3 2 1
não acredito sobem juro
meu deus
mesmo porque tem coisas lá dentro
em um fundo do baú mesmo tá não está
assim em 321 o que vamos lá
a primeira coisa ou é uma taxa
é uma taxa muito grande esta caixa
maliki ultrapassar é não sair e ainda
vai ter que uma coisa não goza de uma
contenda foi segurar aqui dentro que
será o rosto de dilma
você fica mais sério vai ao ataque e 3 2
gotas
o próximo projecto muito ambicioso e 13
não é isso que eu quero fazer é
construir as regras meu link da equipe
posição sobre o total previsto nem
queijo ou outra olha dentro do nosso
valor que será vamos lá ver vou tentar
ficar bem pesada
a fé é de 321 impulso aquelas produzidas
por chão e um ex-alto boel
[Música]
isso se eu soubesse pq ai ai tá muito
difícil mostra um lado mais uma vez por
dia
estamos vindo de outra forma porque já
fiz junto ao mec que temos mais velha e
temos como a granada de impulso mas o
que eu quero tanto março
o curioso fiz acho que foram 321 somba
do são paulo se não acho que estou mal
acho que sim e acho que o filme porque
já sou karina que nem isso não por ser a
segunda rua fogo
o dólar também possui o pessoal pode ser
encontrado por r 323 211 no meu filme só
que estava o pessoal brincava esclarecer
atingir o cuidado vovô henrique tite
alertou andar cura
penso dessa forma vou fazer outro isso
ai ai
o dólar que joga charme para conseguir
isto é que temos as opções doces balas
brincar aí tá muito parecida mesmo
aquela pessoa se mais fraca z é muito
bom só que quer ver mais vídeos culpa o
que fornece comida e eu acho que eu vou
fazer mais
sabe eu acho que há uma pedra
acho que é uma pena 32 o escute jogo
estava igual mesmo assim em bloco b am
10 de junho solo que vou treinar e se
vocês comentário e eu vou tentar
construir uma ficada de preto uma
maneira igual ao do forlife chama de
cada uma rampa tem uma cor e qualquer
coisa impossível comentei muito se
quiserem ver disse que no final meu deus
tem muita coisa que acho que isso também
eu acho que não é só uma redução de 15%
está muito bom ter essa que já tinha
feito em vídeo por um tempo para elas
não virão para só restante muito pouca
coisa não sabe o que tem que se sentir
acima de 2
o phishing
sou criado em volta e fez isso que foi
feito começa por referir às canais z
op outro mundo aqui mas existem bairros
que têm arma também meu viu a mãe não tá
aí então tá
agora não tem mais nada lá dentro não
esperava
onde há fumo há fogo uma bala de pistola
ap estou onde a bola de shot-gun nós
temos o toró é muito importante num
shopping de junho eu igual tá muito
igual olha só o cartucho do prefeito foi
isso que aconteceu aqui
o número 4 pode ser uma faca
o pessoal estava também é um brinquedo
tanto que ela produziu méxico consertar
isso agora é muito parecida jogo mas vou
deixar aqui nós choque é preciso
consultar o estado
estou pronto para a batalha já tinha uma
pistola tem munição uma solução só uma
palavra fora para não trair é bom é
provável que só fique sempre que eu
adoro o som do sol jogar porque começo
do vídeo podem verbal está completamente
vazio já não temos mais cai 3 minutos
mas se vocês quiserem ver mais um vídeo
culpa o dourado forte no haiti como item
que o faz com certeza e deixei muito
mais do que neste vídeo e já não sócios
não só aqui no canal quem está próximo
[Música]